and welcome to hannity and tonight
comedian dave chappelle under attack a
deranged amateur rapper now charged with
assault with a deadly weapon after
storming the stage with a gun-shaped
knife and lunging at the comedian during
a stand-up routine now of course the
incredibly smart and stable ladies of
the view they knew exactly who to blame
who do you think
donald trump
what do you think is happening i mean
it's happening on airplanes it's
happening on street corners people are
just running i mean the hollywood ball i
mean just ran up on you things that
could contribute to what's going on the
pandemic the opioid crisis the fact that
trump was out there saying uh things
like just knock the hell out of them i
promise you i'll pay for the legal fees
when they had a heckler okay so this is
not a political thing come on i know you
want to wrap it all into policy but this
is really about security like i don't
understand why you've been happening
before
it happened what's happening smith
wasn't particularly right leaning and
running up on the stage and smacking
chris rock yeah but i do think that
trump unleashed
some incivility at least
the noise anyway sadly joyless behar has
yet to recover from her very severe case
of trump derangement syndrome thankfully
dave chappelle who i think is
hilariously funny is okay however his
attacker is not looking so good the
assailant suffered multiple injuries
during the attack including an arm that
looks now totally mangled
simple lesson in life if you attack
someone an innocent person uh you might
want to expect to get the living well
adam shift kicked out of you all right
coming up piers morgan we'll get his
reaction also dhs secretary mayorkas on
capitol hill again today where he
struggled yet again to explain why he
hired a far-left activist to police your
thoughts and biden's brand new
ministry of truth uh the full lowlights
that's coming up straight ahead but
first our top story tonight comes to us
from the white house apparently our
cognitively struggling
commander-in-chief thinks that trump
supporters represent the most extreme
political faction in american history
and because of them all gay kids will
soon be banned from going to school
they just make this all up take a look
this is about a lot more than abortion
what happens if you have a state changes
the law saying that that that children
who are lgbtq can't be in classrooms
with other children
is that is that legit under the way the
decision is written
what are the next things that are going
to be attacked
because this mega crowd is really the
most extreme political organization
that's existed in american history
in american history okay we'll deal with
that in a minute obviously that's a
predictable democratic lie we used to
get it every two years four years
republicans racist sexist misogynist
homophobic
xenophobic transphobic you don't you
know the routine but remember obama said
uh
those people in pennsylvania the bitter
ones that cling to their god their guns
their bible religion or as hillary
called uh while half the country a
basket of deplorables or as fbi agent
peter strzok once referred to
conservatives as trump supporting smelly
walmart shoppers now according to biden
76 million americans are the most
extreme political faction in history
half the country joe
now of course everything biden just said
is a simple disgusting political scare
tactic no basis in reality joe is
demagoguing this potential supreme court
ruling in the most dishonest way
possible in fact late justice ruth bader
ginsburg herself once all but predicted
that roe v wade would likely be
overturned because it's on shaky legal
ground and for decades get this joe
biden himself actually agreed with sean
hannity and he wanted roe v wade tossed
out wanted a constitutional amendment
where's the media mob asking joe
what what made him change his mind in
the 70s then senator biden stated quote
i don't like the supreme court decision
on abortion i think it went too far i
don't think that a woman has the sole
right to say what should happen to her
body in the 1980s he supported that
constitutional amendment with the
recently passed orrin hatch of utah and
a constitutional amendment that banned
roe v wade
and letting states decide abortion law
and in 2006 joey had this to say about
abortion take a look
tell me about abortion where do you
stand and how will you face that issue
it's going to be very difficult
i do not view abortion as a uh um as a
choice and a right i think it's always a
tragedy
not a choice or a right according to
biden even more recently yesterday joe
biden referred to roe versus wade as the
ability to abort a child not a fetus a
clump of cells but a child he used the
word take a look
the idea that we're going to make a
judgment
that
is going to say that
no one can make the judgment to choose
to
abort a child
based on a decision by the court i think
goes way overboard
and today our very own peter ducey he
asked circle back jenn saki chief
propagandist for clarification let's
check out her answer
why is the president talking about the
judgment to choose to abort a child
the president's view on a woman's right
to make choices about her own health
care is well-known well-documented
well-stated he said abort a child i
understand peter but what i'm telling
you is what his position is and how can
you guys say this is not a political
issue
when the president's statement about
this talked about getting pro-choice
officials elected did i say it's not a
political issue uh yes you actually said
some called a political issue it is not
now no one really knows what joe biden
thinks about abortion or frankly
anything for that matter uh he may not
even know any of this himself but the
marching orders have been issued and now
the entire democratic party is hell-bent
on lying to you the american people and
using this issue to inflame voters
listen to vice president kamala harris
from late last night take a look
those republican leaders who are trying
to weaponize the use of the law against
women
will we say
how dare they
how dare they tell a woman what she can
do and cannot do with her own body
how dare they
[Applause]
how dare they try to stop her from
determining her own future
how dare they
try to deny women
their
and their freedoms
if it is overturned abortion will still
be totally legal in most every state
abortion access will exist for every
american so the question is why are they
demagomic demagoguing the issue and
lying to you the american people because
every one of their policies have failed
that's the distraction now is it an
important issue yeah do people have
strong passionate views on it yes will
abortion still be legal in america yes
states like new york california they'll
have the most liberal laws and while the
american people are evenly divided on
the issue of abortion the vast majority
of americans are deeply worried about
other things you know the economy
40-year high of inflation highest gas
prices we've ever paid high prices the
highest we paid for everything we buy in
every store we go to the disaster in
afghanistan the war in europe the crisis
at our southern border poor leadership
in dc now these are issues that directly
impact every american every single day
and by the way they know who to blame
joe biden is an unmitigated disaster and
every poll shows it so all democrats the
media mob they want to inflame your
emotions they want you to focus on only
one topic they don't want to talk about
any of the failures of joe biden as a
matter of fact the mob and the media
they cover for joe biden they'll tell
you that the world is coming to an end
it's not true they'll try to use
abortion as a political wedge and lied
to you and then you'll realize oh
abortion is still legal the states
decide we will tell you the cold hard
truth separate fact from fiction we'll
bring you the facts and we will cover
all of the issues that impact you the
american people day in and day out the
left has lost touch with reality they
have no good story to tell obama hillary
you just need to tell your story they
don't have a story to tell unless they
make one up there's only one way to
bring them back to earth and that's for
you the american people to show up at
the polls vote them out of office in six
months if you've not registered i
strongly suggest you do it now because
in these six months we are now facing a
very pivotal inflection point in this
country pivotal election a turning point
election now get this right now as of
tonight every single candidate that
president trump has endorsed in a
primary oh look at his record 55-0
wow hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else